Hey guys, welcome to episode two of my
GE only challenge. I decided to make
another one quicker than I had initially
thought I would uh because of just the
amount of support I got on the first
episode. So, thank you guys. We got over
300 likes on the episode. Could we get
300 in this one as well? I don't know.
Um but if you guys are enjoying the
series, please toss a video like. Uh and
uh yeah, so just to do a little bit
introduction for those who may have not
seen the first episode, uh we're stuck
in the Grand Exchange, but we have
access to a couple extra areas as uh we
get higher total levels or unlock uh via
buying it with money. Uh so you can see
the map here. We haven't unlocked
anything yet because we have not gotten
250 total level or 10 mil cash. Uh but
we're getting pretty close. I think we
could probably hit the 250 total level
this episode. that will allow us access
to the palace where we can train our uh
well we can get better woodcutting
experience. Uh we can get actual combat
experience because there are guards
there to fight and uh eventually we can
get farming as well. Uh at 300 total
level that will be unlocked. Uh but
still nothing unlocked so far. So hope
you guys enjoy. Uh and let's get started
with episode number two. All right guys,
so for the first flip of the episode, we
have the samurai shirt coming in at only
about a 20k margin on that. Not bad.
We're also looking to sell off the
Gothics rope tops that we bought. Bought
those for about 48k each. And the
adamant canes. Uh looking to flip those
as well. That has a mediocre margin, but
I want to leave some money or some items
in the GE. Uh next up, we're looking to
train our fletching. Uh so we were doing
arrow shafts before, but they kind of
suck. So now that we have some money,
we're just going to straight up buy some
logs and then we can make short bows,
long bows, and uh get our fletching at
least to 20. So, I believe uh to get it
to 20, we're going to need about 330
logs. Uh then that should be enough. All
right, we're just finishing up long
bows. We made some short bows, but it
was so quick there's no point of
mentioning it. So, there we go. 20
fletching. Now, we can make the oak
short bow. So, I've done that
calculation, and I believe we need,
let's see here, 205 oak logs, uh at
least to get all the short bows made.
So, we'll go ahead grind out these short
bows. All right, there we go. We're just
finishing up the oak short bows. That is
going to get us to level 25 uh pretty
quick. Now we can make the oak long bow.
We'll go ahead and buy some more oak
logs and uh we are losing money on
pretty much every one of these
unfortunately uh cuz they're worthless.
But once we get up to maple and you
we'll actually start profiting from
fletching which will actually be kind of
nice. All right, to get to uh the willow
short bow we're going to need 600 oak
logs roughly as we'll go ahead and cut
those and be back in a minute. All
right, the flips are back in and
apparently it was an adamant halbird.
That's funny. Uh, so we bought the Adam
Halbirds for 78K and it looks like we
flipped them for 102K. Not bad. And the
Gothics rope tops we bought for like
178K. Uh, so a really good margin on
those. Sold them for 261. Pretty happy
with that. Uh, so next up, we're going
to try the Gothic robe legs. Uh, looks
like they actually dropped down to an
extremely cheap price. We'll try sniping
some for 15k. Uh, we'll leave an offer
in for six of them. Uh, so I'm looking
at the barrows repair section on GE
Tracker and then I realize I can't
actually repair uh armor items until I
have leveled up my house. So that's a
good goal. Uh, once I get to 50
construction, I'll be able to repair
items in my house and then I can do this
moneymaking method. Otherwise, I need to
go to Lumbridge or out of the GE,
unfortunately. So, this is not actually
going to work. Uh, but yeah,
construction, I think, is what I'm going
to buy first. I've never had a high
construction level and uh it seems a lot
more useful than having a moderately
high herblower level. I mean like
getting 75 construction for the burners
is going to be important because uh
using just regularly burying bones is
extremely bad. And uh yeah, so we're
definitely going to want to get 75
construction for the burners and the um
the gilded altar. Uh but anyway, yeah,
construction definitely all the way. Uh
we decided on the miss battle staff
instead. We'll try buying them for about
100k and we can sell them maybe for a
20k margin which is not bad. Okay, the
miss battle staffs are back in. Uh we
sold them for a 30k profit on each one.
Uh netting us about 120k. Uh really good
especially for the cash stack. We're at
100k from 400k is extremely good. Uh so
pretty happy with that. Uh next up I
think we might just put in another offer
for the mystic um mistaf now this time.
Close but not the same. Uh kind of hard
to say as well. We're going to try
buying them for about 135k and flipping
them for about a 40k profit. Again, very
nice. I'll put them in for 141 just to
be a little bit higher up. And we'll do
uh three. Uh next up, the Zamarak miter.
Looks really good. Um actually trades
more than I thought it would, but uh
looks like a 30k margin on an item
that's relatively cheap. Uh Zamarak
miter.
And uh yeah, looks like we can buy it
for about 51k and sell it for roughly
90k. Uh, so actually I'll put a 40k
margin. So we'll try buying them for 55k
and leave that in as well. All right, so
we're just cutting some oak long bows
right now. Uh, this should get us to 35
fletching. Now we can make the willow
shore. Uh, which is pretty nice. It'll
increase our XP rate even more. Also, we
did manage to buy uh both Zamarak miters
and sell one for 90k um not 90k margin,
but a 40k margin. Uh, so we're
definitely going to put another offer in
for those. These are coming in really
quickly. Uh, we just did like 10 minutes
of fletching and we already bought two
and sold one. So, not bad. Uh, next up,
we're going to buy some willow logs. Uh,
luckily the willow logs are really
cheap, so we'll just buy a thousand.
We'll actually lose less money on this
section, which is nice. All right, we're
just cutting some willow short bows.
This should bring us to 40 fletching
still relatively quickly. Uh, and now we
can make willow long bows. So, I think
it's not until Maple short bows that we
can start uh profiting from fletching.
Uh we'll actually start stringing some
of the bows soon because it actually is
more profitable. All right, guys. We're
back and uh we've only flipped one of
the mystic mist staffs uh for about 35k.
Uh so we're not going to do more of
those and the items kind of hard to say,
so not going to do that. Uh but these
miters um we've probably flipped about
five of these so far for about a 30k
profit on each one. Uh which is
extremely good. We have another three
we're waiting to sell. But look, we
bought four for 244K and sold four for
316K. bought two for 110k and sold two
for 158k. Uh so yeah, 28k on or 25k
maybe on each one and we'll put another
offer in for four. Uh so we're going to
take this opportunity to uh train my
range up a little bit. We've boughten
some iron darts and some steel darts and
just some newbie range gear. Uh so we're
going to go ahead train an imps and just
try to get our range to around five just
for some easy to levels. All right,
there's level three range. Uh it's
actually really really slow because all
I can is ones. Uh, so we do have the
steel darts that we can wear at five,
but it just takes a long time to find
all the imps. So, I'm not going to train
it too high. All right, we actually hit
a hit point level, our second one. So,
there's 12 hit points. That's kind of
nice. But again, most of our combat
experience is going to come from the
guards. So, we're not going to waste too
much time here. All right, there we go.
There's level five range. Uh, we're just
going to cut that for now. But, we can
use the steel darts. I wonder if we can
even hit a two yet. I don't know. All
we've hit is one for the longest time.
Uh so with our remaining cash, we went
ahead and bought 400 uh casts of the
level two enchant. Uh this will net us a
profit of I don't know, maybe 30 or 40k,
but mainly it's going to get us some
magic experience. Uh we're going to try
to get to 43 magic on this episode so we
can use the super heat spell uh in the
future cuz that'll be pretty nice to get
actually some smithing experience. I
swear to God, somebody liter Oh my god,
someone just dropped a dragon scimitar.
Some guy's been dropping um scimitars
and a warrior ring. Oh, there's no way
I'm getting that one. Uh, get can we get
it? Hey, we got two dragon simmitars.
That's actually really nice. Oh, get the
N. Can we get the third one? Uh, yeah.
Random world. This isn't even a popular
world. I just saw warriors ringing
around. What the [__] Uh, I don't think
we can get that one. You have to be
ahead of the crowd. You can't be a
sheep. Uh, if you want to get items, you
got to think for yourself. Oh, [__] I
don't think we get anything else. Uh, so
we only managed to get two dragon
scitars, but that's really good. That's
like 100k right there. Uh, and we're
actually just about to hit a magic
level. Uh, we did all 400 of these, uh,
casts. Uh, took probably 20 30 minutes,
not too long. And that is going to get
us 40 magic, which is pretty exciting.
We only need another three magic levels.
And then we can use the super heat
spell. Uh, so we'll withdraw all the
rings of dueling. Let's just see how
much we profited off of this. We
actually had to buy a couple more rings
because we dropped them to get the
scimitar. And we got our two scimitars
as well. Uh, so we'll sell off the
scimitars. Looks like about 60k each.
really good for just picking a random
item up and sell off these rings of
dueling as well. And we'll hit collect
and well no we'll collect them manually.
So the rings of dueling we sold for
roughly 400k and bought the ingredients
for about uh 360k so about a 30 40k
profit. Uh pretty good for just
profitable magic experience. Anyway, uh
next up we wanted to put an offer in for
the ancient page 2. Uh looks like I had
a pretty good margin on GE Tracker. So,
we'll go buy two of those for about 276k
each. All right, so we have some logs
coming in and oak logs. And what we're
going to plan on training now is fire
making. Uh really easy get skill to
train. Should be quick. Uh we'll need
about 100 regular logs to get to 15 and
then we can use oak logs or burn oak
logs, I should say. There's level 15
fire making uh from regular logs. Now we
can burn oak logs. Uh the only reason
we're getting our firemaking up is of
course for total levels. There isn't
really any practical use to getting my
fire making up, but uh it's nice to get
some fast experience and some easy to
levels. All right, we just hit 200 total
level. Uh which is pretty exciting. Only
50 more until we've unlocked the palace.
Uh we're also about to get another
firemaking level, I believe. Uh it's
just look how quick it is just to get
firemaking levels. Like that was 30
experience per burn. Except when your
character just [__] around like this.
But come on, light the log. I already
started the recorder. I can take it back
now. Any second now. Oh my god. There we
go. And 60 experience. 60 experience.
And there we go. That should be level 30
firemaking. We can now burn willow logs,
which will be even cheaper uh and even
quicker experience. Uh so one thing I'm
actually going to do is buy some big
bones. Uh I think they're the most cost
effective bone. uh cuz we are going to
manually bury them uh for some easy
prayer levels, but uh it's going to be
expensive and there's just no point of
leveling up our prayer until we've
gotten a guilded altar. Uh so we're just
going to use this for the total level,
but we're not actually going to grind
out uh many of these bones cuz even
though big bones aren't that expensive,
uh it's going to add up. I mean, 100
bones was 30k and it'll only take me
like a minute or two to bury them. Uh
but anyway, we did buy an ancient page
as well uh for the 250 or something we
bought it for and we're looking to sell
it for 338 uh for a 60k margin. All
right, there is level five prayer just
from burying these bones very quick. Uh
but going to get really expensive once
we start to bury more, but we're getting
15 per berry and about 26k an hour. All
right, there we go. We're just finishing
up all the rest of the bones we had. Got
us to 11 prayer. Uh nothing special at
11 prayer, but anyway, uh actually we're
getting about 46k uh prayer experience
an hour. Still pretty shitty in the
grand scheme of things, but it'll work
for now. And we sold off an ancient page
for 338k. That is a 60k profit. Not bad.
As well as we sold another zamarak
miter. Uh so our cash stack is getting
pretty close to 1 mil. Uh which is
pretty exciting. First 1 mil cash stack
of the series. Uh so with the money,
we're going to buy another ancient page
2. Uh just been such a profitable item.
Uh we're just going to take this one out
and put in an offer for two of them at
276k. And then we'll leave a bit of
money if we can spell page. That is
leave a bit of money for training cuz I
think we're going to level up our
crafting a little bit. Again, a bunch of
easy total levels. Uh but two ancient
pages for 276k each. All right, so we
boughten a bunch of crafting supplies
about 100 leather uh for 25k. Uh that
money is pretty much all sacrifice.
We're not getting any money back, but it
should be pretty quick. Uh we're going
to have to do leather items all the way
to glass blowing because we can't uh use
a furnace right now. Uh unless you guys
have a suggestion for a better way. I
think leather items is going to be the
best. All right, there's seven crafting.
Uh we can now make the leather boot and
yeah, pretty quick. All right, so we're
just training using van braces right
now. Well, we're pretty well done them.
H and that is going to be 14 crafting.
Now we can make the leather armor and uh
well, leather chaps is going to be the
best we can make for a while. And it
looks like it's about 46k an hour, 50k
an hour. So, we'll only have to do about
an hour of chaps till we can do the
glass blowing. So, that's not too bad.
All right, there we go. We're just about
to hit 18 crafting. And now we can make
the leather chaps. So, this will be
about an hour of chaps and then we can
get to uh 46 crafting. Uh so, not
terrible, I guess. There's level 23
crafting. Uh well, we can now make
sapphire bracelets, but we don't have
access to a furnace, unfortunately,
right now, so we cannot do that. All
right, so we just flipped a ancient page
2 once again for a 60k profit. Very
nice. Uh they're coming in very quickly
as well. We also had to go ahead and buy
some more leather because we ran out.
Another We'll do another 200 leather. Uh
cuz it is Oh, I guess we'll do 300. It's
a little expensive because uh well,
that's 60 90k down the drain. All right,
we're just about to hit another crafting
level. There is 30 crafting. Uh these
chops really aren't too bad, although it
would be kind of nice to be able to make
something else. But now we can make some
emerald bracelets if we wanted. All
right, so like I said at the beginning
of the episode, I did want to get 43
magic so I can use the super heat spell
in the coming episodes. Uh, so we're
going to do another 360 cast of the
level two enchant, which will be enough
to get us to 43 uh, magic, and then we
can get some smithing experience. All
right, and we have another successful
flip of the ancient page, too. We're
getting 60k on each one, which is
extremely good. Uh, we also bought
another one. Uh, we'll put it in for
That's not the right price. Don't put in
for 276, please. Uh, take that out. We
want to sell it for 338K. Uh, so a
pretty good margin there. And we'll put
another offer in for another ancient
page 2 at 276 and call that a day. All
right, this is going to be it. This will
be the last level of the episode. Uh,
going to get to 43 magic. Now we can use
the super heat spell. Uh, while the
experience isn't that great, again,
going to be some nice total levels and
just nice all around to get some
smithing experience. And there we go,
guys. That is level 250 total level as
well, which is really awesome. Uh, now
we have access to the palace. Uh, but I
think that's where we're going to end it
for today, guys. So, sorry if it's a
cliffhanger. Didn't mean to make it this
way. Well, I kind of did. But anyway,
we'll sell off all our items. Rings of
dueling and the rings of dueling. And
we'll pull out as much money as we can.
Uh, well, we got the buy offers in.
We'll just leave that for now. But I
think our cash stack is around 1 mil
right now. Uh, which is pretty good, I
would say. Uh, another 500k made on this
episode. Hopefully, we can get it to a
bit higher after that. Uh, but let's go
have a look at the area. We now have
access to the palace. Uh, so of course
we have the U trees in the north. Uh,
which will get unlocked. Well, not for a
while. Uh, but more importantly for wood
cutting, we have access to oak trees,
which is awesome. Just down here. Oak
trees there. Perfect. Uh, three of them
will be perfectly enough. Uh, never will
have to bank, I don't think. And, uh,
next, uh, the most important thing that
we have access to is a farming patch. uh
which is just over here to the right. Uh
we will not unlock that until 300 total
level. And even then, while I could
unlock it by raking it, uh I could also
unlock it in my home, but I won't have
my home unlocked till I have 10 mil
cash. So, I'm not really sure what I
should do there. Also, there are guards
to train on, which I'm really excited to
actually get some combat levels. So, I
really hope you guys enjoyed episode 2.
Thank you again for all the support on
the first episode, and I will see you
guys in the next one.
[Music]